now special treatment for a celebrity or
justice good evening to you thank you
for joining us at six i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez a husband and wife
visiting las vegas say a former ufc
fighter attacked them and four other
people and now they're livid about a
recent turn in the case against him they
spoke first with the a news now i-team's
vanessa murphy who has this report from
the regional justice center in downtown
las vegas
former ufc fighter chael sonnen is only
facing misdemeanor charges now and at
least two of the people who he's accused
of randomly beating are upset a felony
charge is dropped i'm completely shocked
i'm
extremely disappointed to learn of this
news
i think
for me it just takes me back to that to
that day
julie and christopher still fluke says
shael sonnen attacked them as they were
walking to their hotel room at the four
seasons on december 18th chris was
watching me get beaten by him i was
watching him choke my husband this
is an individual that did this for a
living to beat people into submission
this is video taken moments after
according to this metro report sonnen
told police he took an ambien earlier in
the day and didn't remember what
happened he received five citations for
battery it appears he was not taken to
jail it was incredibly violent it is it
for us or for me anyway it is the most
traumatizing experience i've ever had
the stealth flugs say they were both
diagnosed with concussions and they
provided the i-team with these medical
documents julie says sonnen split her
lip open christopher says he still had
these marks around his neck a few days
later initially the clark county
district attorney charged sonan with
battery by strangulation a felony along
with 10 misdemeanor battery counts but
in this amended complaint filed by
prosecutors here in court wednesday
sonnen now only faces six misdemeanor
battery charges they object to this
reduction of charges they were never
consulted by the da's office attorney
corey kaplan is representing the stealth
lukes who live in california i got a
call and said
we're reducing it back down to
misdemeanors and
we're going to file the motion attorney
david figler is representing sonin who
he says lives out of state commend the
district attorney for taking a look
checking their own work this is the
check and balance system of the criminal
justice system and today it works but
the stealth flukes say the criminal
justice system failed them the take-home
message from this morning was basically
don't go to vegas and get involved with
an incident with a celebrity because the
criminal justice is not there it feels
um just like we're being re-victimized
in that hallway and i'm watching this
monster beat my wife all over again
they've now filed a civil lawsuit
against sonnen he needs some sort of
repercussions for his actions
the next date for sonnen's criminal case
is set for april 27th reporting in
downtown las vegas vanessa murphy live
local now
the 8 news now i-team reached out to
metro and the clark county district
attorney's office metro police say that
he was cited at the scene due to it
being a misdemeanor battery that did not
occur in police presence the assistant
district attorney tells the i-team
police and prosecutors reviewed witness
statements medical documents and photos
and concluded it did not rise to the
level of a felony he strongly disputes
that sonan is getting special treatment
misdemeanor counts carry a maximum
sentence of six months